mr. Randall nicely done by Simmons who
had switched sham it for a free thought
it times how you could never tell but
individually he was yearning to get back
out there and I seem to take advantage
it might never come on
I'm sorry sham it for three well the
light is hard for him tonight the green
light that is most of minutes on the
bench as possible yes Larry Shannon has
it going on here in the first half young
fella 4 of 7 from beyond a little bit
bitter against Portland after road trip
looks a lot different no doubt Chabot
has been hot from beyond continues to be
sizzling finishing by both teams shaman
another three
the rookie a career-high six threes is
an opportunity for him to start
reassuring himself to roll-out Chabot
again yes how big does the bucket look
too young Landry shamit right now who's
the third
[Applause]
Hey three-pointers for Landry Chabot
give him 27 sheets again you know that
they're going for him that's usually
JJ's play the little dho dribble handoff
to Landry